So starting with getting your project to compile and the options available to us
There's several different configurations
That we can use by default and several different targets so configurations on the left targets on the right
So we have debug, debug game, development, test and shipping
Debug essentially means that both the Unreal Engine itself and your games code will both be completely unoptimized
So for the most comprehensive debugging experience obviously that means that affects performance and load times
Debug game very similar, but only your games code will be unoptimized and more just to optimize the actual Unreal Engine code as normal
Development is the kind of default configuration that most people on the team would be using certainly non programmers
This is essentially
Most of the code is optimized this allows for some amount of debugging
But it will you know your load times your performance will be a lot improved
So for people who actually don't need to be looking at the code, they typically be using this configuration
Test is allowing
most optimizations, but
It will keep developer tools and the ability to kind of use console commands in the various targets
Shipping is everything is fully optimized. No profiling tools. No console commands allowed
So shipping is you know the game as it will go to the public then we have our targets
This is essentially where that code is going what kind of code
What is the kind of like receiving product for this code? So client and server relatively obvious
It's intending a build for specifically for the client of the game or a server
Editor is again the kind of default one. This is building your actual game in the context of the Unreal editor
in worth highlighting that each of these has
Pragmas that link to it
So in on client mode we have with client and code inside the with client code pragmas will only be executed on client builds
The same with with server code, but in editor both with client and with server are always true
So editor kind of has both of those as true. So it treats itself as a birth client and server
Game that is the kind of last target and that is the first two were both true
Game is the kind of standalone single-player version of the game
So if you're making a multiplayer game, it's unlikely you're going to be using the game target
but if you're making a standalone game if you're creating if you're
creating a package of your game your games like a single-player game, that's the target you would be using and
Both client code and server code pragmas would be true in that situation. Both of those things are true, but obviously
Editor isn't true in that case because you're not shipping that with the editor
One last thing to touch on as well is that test and shipping
Neither of those configurations can be used in conjunction with editor. So test and shipping
configurations are expressly intended for actual like
Packaged versions of your game just quickly touching on the unreal editor itself
It's a lot more than just a scripting tool
It's not just for level designers to come in create levels and do a little bit of scripting
There's actually a huge range of comprehensive features that would be far too, you know
It needs its own presentation just to say even touch on all the stuff that the editor provides
But there is a lot of functionality there for every discipline as programmers. It's got a lot of powerful debugging tools
Blueprint itself is kind of an important skill set to add to your tool belt
So we'll touch on that a little bit more in a second
And also one of the really really powerful things is it provides you a way to
actually test if you're doing a multiplayer game or
Yes, either online multiplayer or even local multiplayer game
It gives you a really really easy way to test your game in a multiplayer environment on a single device
I'll actually just quickly demo that we just go to an example project. I've created
I'm a different session will explain kind of more of an introduction to the editor itself
So you just have to kind of believe what I'm doing
But I can just change the number of players this demo this game is going to demo
So if I just played like this, you can see I'm just kind of like a single-player running around not not super compelling gameplay yet
But if I want to just demo what this game would be like with two players
I can literally just change this number here. And now I have a two-player game
I have two separate versions of the game
And if I had a character model, you would literally see both characters and you'd be moving around in real time
But I can also switch from that that is the equivalent of doing like local multiplayer
I can also suddenly switch to multiplayer mode and you can see I've created a little
Widget here in the top left that demonstrates that this screen is actually on the server and this screen is on the client
and so you can really really easily debug network replication issues and
Understand exactly how a client and a server would be communicating information and issues that might come up in a kind of networked multiplayer
Context so a really really powerful tool to be aware of from the off and as well as like I said the debug capabilities
And the use of blueprint
Yeah again worth highlighting that
Projects can be written in both C++ and blueprints even if you're using the epic launcher version, so you don't have to
Download the source built version of the engine to use C++. You can do C++ and blueprints in in any context
But if you do want access to the source, it is freely available via the epic games github
So by default you get engine through the epic games launcher. That is you can
See but not debug the unreal source
so when you go to download a version of the engine, it'll look something like this and you have this option here to download the
Engine source, you can download the editor symbols for debugging. Sorry, but you can't edit the engine source code. So if
You actually need to be able to change some things about the way the engine works
That's absolutely fine
But you will just need to download the engine from the github just to quickly demonstrate what that looks like
I've actually got it in the second window over here. You can just visit
github.com slash epic games slash unreal engine and this is the repo for the unreal engine
There's the source version
We've got tags for every release going all the way back to some time before I even started
Yeah, unreal 4.0
So
Really really comprehensive amazing tool and a really good way to say you're on version 5.5
And you need to pull some functionality back
You can actually jump to
changes that were made on
5.6 and look at all those changes and how they are made and maybe pull some of those functionalities back if you want to
Stay on the same engine, but pull back some more recent changes
Worth highlighting that if you do want to have access to the source built version of the engine
You will need to connect your github account with your unreal engine account, which doesn't take very long
You can also access the source version of the engine through the unreal engine perforce
But that is explicitly for unreal engine licensees. So there's a kind of a couple of extra steps required there
But the github it's freely available to everyone